hello everyone and welcome to today's
keynote presentation measurements and
standards to support confidence in
genome editing presented by dr. samantha
mirage leader of the genome editing
program at the National Institute of
Standards and Technology
I'm dr. Susie Valdez of lab roots and
I'll be your moderator for today's event
we're delighted to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by
labyrinth yeah Brad's is the leading
scientific social networking website and
producer of educational virtual events
and webinars before we begin I want to
remind everyone that this event is
interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time you
want during the presentation just click
on that ask a question box on the left
of your screen and type your questions
into the drop-down box that appear on
the screen our speaker will respond to
your questions via email if you have any
trouble seeing or hearing this
presentation just click on that ask a
question box and let us know you're
having a problem this presentation is
educational and thus offers continuing
education credits just click on that
continuing education credits tab located
at the top right hand corner of your
presentation window and follow the
process to obtain those credits without
further ado please join me in welcoming
our keynote presenter dr. samantha
mirage i will now turn the presentation
over to her welcome dr. mirage thank you
so much for having me I'm so glad to be
here to present at this inaugural lab
roots meeting on CRISPR technologies so
my name is samantha mirage I'm from the
US National Institute of Standards and
Technology and many of you may not be
familiar with us but I'm going to
familiarize you with who we are what we
do and how we're impacting the field of
genome editing so the talk title is
measurements and standards to support
confidence in genome editing so first
I'll go over the talk and the outline
for today so I'm gonna give you an
introduction to NIST and what
measurement assurance is this may be a
title in term that you're not familiar
with so what exactly that means and how
it's important and impacts every aspect
of the science that you do next
I'll go into the measurement challenges
for genome editing as a field where
CRISPR is one of the leading
technologies and then I'm going to
introduce you to the nice genome editing
consortium and that is an effort started
here at NIST to support the genome
editing community and translation of
these technology space into industry and
potentially products that can impact our
everyday life so we'll begin with an
introduction to NIST so nest who are we
NIST as I mentioned is the u.s. national
metrology Institute so our goal is
global harmonization of measurements it
sounds like it might not really fit into
the thought process of where biology is
but everything around you everything you
do is based on some measurement time
weight how much volume is in your pipe
header all of these things are
measurements and NIST were the people
that help make sure that you understand
whether those measurements are correct
we also consider ourselves industries
labs so NIST is part of the Department
of Commerce so we're not part of Health
and Human Services like NIH or FDA we're
part of a different part of the
government and our job is to help us
competitiveness and translation of
technologies so our mission is really in
the cutting edge of technology
measurements and standards when you go
to the doctor and they take your
cholesterol how do you know that that
answers right we're the people that are
working to help make sure that there's
confidence and those kinds of
measurements so those other kinds of
measurements and technology so
technology development transfer
something that we also do so how can we
help a new technology space like the
genome editing field develop tools that
meet new kinds of measurement
capabilities biology
so if you are familiar with this you may
know of us as the people that make the
atomic clock that time is calibrated to
or weights of measures but NIST is also
very focused and engaged in the biology
sector and so that means biology that
has to do with pharmaceuticals biology
that might have to do with food or other
sorts of health or environment are the
kinds of things that we also support so
we work very closely with other
government agencies with industry with
those that are at the cutting edge of
research development in order to help
translate these technologies in these
tools and so NIST
we're measurement people so we draw from
our broad range of expertise and
measurement science to apply to the new
and growing types of challenges and we
are the trusted party so NIST
we're not regulatory we don't enforce
anything on people but we are there to
partner so we're a trusted third party
we are meant to be unbiased and provide
that level of collaboration in this
sector so now I'm giving you a little
bit of an introduction to NIST I want to
give you an introduction to why and how
NIST is interacting in the biology space
so there's been over the last several
years this recognition of this concept
of reproducibility there have been in
several studies and I'm just
highlighting one here into the economics
of this how much money is going into the
biological sciences and how much money
maybe isn't being used effectively
because of irreproducible 'ti and so
there is a burden on our research
environment of data that's that's not
reproducible but the question really is
is that the goal is the goal to be able
to get the same number over and over
again so I would suggest that the answer
that is no you can reproduce a number
but that doesn't mean that you're
confident that the numbers right for
example you could set your clock five
minutes ahead because you want to make
sure that you
places on time every time you look at
your clock at 7:00 in the morning it
tells you that it's 655 you can do that
every day day in and day out somebody
else can look at your clock but that
doesn't mean that you have confidence
that it is actually seven o'clock so
that's the kind of thing that we're
talking about these things can be
systemic biases or there can be things
in your system that you can reproduce
the same number every time and it still
might not be the right thing so the idea
is we should go beyond reproducibility
we should really understand the
measurements that we're making and what
might cause them to be impacted so we
need to understand what it is that we're
trying to measure how the process works
to measure it what are the ways that
measurement can be impacted to assess
whether we're really confident in the
data that we have and that we trust it
to make important decisions so if we dig
into these concepts that go beyond
reproducibility what do they look like
so why might you get irreproducible 'ti
it might be a system of a broader
challenge and biomedical research so
every produce ability it might not
actually be your enemy it might be
telling you something about what's
actually happening maybe you don't get
the same result because this lot of your
reagent is actually biologically
different than a new lot of reagent
maybe this lot of cells is biologically
different than another lot of cells and
it's telling you that something real is
happening because biology is very
complex and the systems that we use to
measure biology can be very complex from
the nist perspective what you really
need is really rigorous ways of
assessing your process and understanding
whether your process is trustworthy and
so why and how might you be able to get
some of that confidence understand
whether the answer is right that comes
in having some control materials or some
statistical tools
maybe some reference data that can help
you understand whether the answer that
you got on a particular day maybe at a
particular time maybe a particular
operator is trustworthy and if it's
reasonable to expect that result and
what you really need is it requires some
some initial work some initial testing
to say what is the right range to expect
and so those sorts of biological tools
which lead to greater confidence are
sometimes the tools that NIST helps
develop or helps a community implement
so if you don't really remember any of
that and if you are still struggling
with this idea of confidence in your
data this is really the one slide to
really take away from this conversation
right now and so the sources of pre
analytical and analytical variability
they have to be accounted for to tease
out true biological signal so what we're
really saying here is that at the end of
a process you may run a sample and you
may get a positive on your sample
whatever positive means for your system
and you may say there's a difference
between this sample that I got a
positive on and this other sample that
you have a negative on and you want to
be able to move forward with that
understanding but why are you getting a
positive signal is it really the biology
or is it because these two samples are
run on two different days and on one day
the instrument wasn't working the same
way or they're run by two different
operators and one of the operators gets
a different answer than the other so you
really need to understand what are the
ways that your result might be impacted
by the different factors that are part
of your measurement process to be able
to say I believe that this result is
attributable to the biology that I'm
trying to measure as opposed to these
assay or these instrument variables or
these human variables that are causing
that result so then how do we even go
about this process what makes good data
so what makes good data we've formulated
a little a list that gives some
understanding of these principles of
metrology or measurement science so
sometimes these terms are used
interchangeably but they really do have
to Street in different definitions that
can help you understand your data better
so this idea of precision so replication
reproducibility within a certain context
you can have that you can have a really
good precision you don't necessarily
have accuracy the results might not
actually be true to the expected that
you would see and that's where if you
have different kinds of measurements
trying to measure the same kind of thing
then that can get you at some accuracy
what is actually the correct value how
close are you to the correct value
robustness so if you change if you are
meant to pipette ten microliters if you
pipette ten point one does that matter
if you pipette 11 does that matter how
robust is your system does it matter if
you use a different instrument let's say
you're doing PCR doesn't matter which
PCR instrument you use how robust is
your process that's what we're talking
about here now knowledge of the limits
of detection of your acid it's very
important there are often times that you
get data that's reproducible but it's
outside the dynamic range of your assay
which really means your ass they can't
give you reliable information in that
space that you're getting signal and so
you may get that signal reproducibly but
it's not actually the value that you're
measuring that you can trust
so this often happens with with assays
when we we don't characterize the limits
of detection and we make the mistake of
using values that are outside the
dynamic range now this is a big one for
nist the use of benchmark materials so
one of the things that this does is
generate benchmark materials that can
help a community
understand what their measurement
pipeline is giving them so sometimes we
call these things truth in a bottle
something that has some value that's
certified that lets you understand
whether in your hands in your process
you're getting the right value because
we've given you a value that you should
expect to get and very importantly and
something that we can all do better at I
feel is reporting so we often do very
important things and very sophisticated
things and do very good and thorough
science and sometimes it gets lost in
the reporting process and data and the
metadata how you arrived at your answer
are really critical to understanding a
measurement process and understanding
the quality of your data because it may
be in the details and not the final
answer that's what's causing a lack of
comparability or reproducibility what
one should expect to get reproducibility
so I just mentioned reference materials
so let me tell you about the kinds of
things that mis generates I've given you
some concepts for the kinds of
challenges that you deal with every day
in your research that we might be able
to help with what NIST does here but
these are the physical kinds of things
that NIST
actually delivers to people documentary
standards so these are norms or
protocols that are able to help come to
some normalization within a field
reference materials I just mentioned was
these are physical things that you can
get in your hands that have some
certified value so that you know in your
hands whether you're getting the right
answer and reference data so these are
data sets databases where the data that
goes along with some of these reference
materials or these reference protocols
that you can get in your hands and for
your information your bioinformatics
pipelines and processes you can see and
see if those sorts of tools are giving
you reliable outputs so how are these
things all built up so we talked about
NIST
I tell you that we're not a regulatory
agency we don't enforce standards
answers are always adopted by consensus
by experts in the community
so we work collaboratively and it begins
with assays so what are the assays that
we want to understand then it goes on to
the measurement assurance so what are
the ways that we use to understand how
how these assays perform so we use
things like inter lab studies where we
send a sample to multiple labs and see
what answers people get and maybe why
those answers might be different as well
as design of experiments taking an assay
and saying well where are all the places
that are really critical that if you
change something here you might get a
different answer and then eventually if
it's the right kind of output to be
developed that might result in guidance
guidance or methods that are normalized
here's one real example that I want to
give you of work something that NIST has
done and developed that's really
relevant to the genome editing space and
the CRISPR field as it's developing and
becoming more mature so this genome in a
bottle consortium is a mislead effort to
address the issue has started several
years ago around 2012 to address the
issue of next-generation sequencing so
this was this shift in technology which
we have all come to recognize as a very
powerful resource that's pretty much a
part of most people's in pipelines right
now and that is a powerful tool that
wanted to have an application in the
clinic and one of the challenges with a
new technology is how do you know if you
can trust it especially to use for very
important kinds of applications and so
this was where the next-generation
sequencing tool makers wanted to be able
to use these devices as clinical
diagnostic devices so to be able to
diagnose genetic disorders and things of
that nature or to be able to screen for
for genetic variants and this was one of
those things well how do you know if
these sorts of tools are supposed to be
able to find the unknown unknown the
next-generation sequencers you put
whatever in and you should figure out
what it see
one says then how would the FDA know if
the information was was true you're
giving back sequence out of the NGS
sequencer but is it biologically
associated with the sample you actually
put in the process so this worked with a
wide group of collaborators and experts
in the DNA sequencing space and the
bioinformatics base to develop this
material and it is the single most
highly characterized human genome set of
materials that are out there and these
materials were used to to to get the
first genome sequencer into the clinic
for NGS sequencing to be a clinical
device and so we partnered with FDA is
NIST an FDA to be able to address this
challenge and so this material is useful
for anybody who wants to understand how
variable is their general genome editing
process it's purified DNA then this has
certified the every base within this
human genome so if we say that there's
an a at this position we say it's an a
and here's our confidence that that it
actually is an A and we've collaborated
widely to make sure that this material
is really fit for the purpose that it
was designed for and so this is
something that allows you there's this
stoplight here and the stoplight is we
refer to these as as yellow light
standards if you get the sample in your
hands you run it through your NGS
process and you get the correct
information and by correct I'm saying
the information that is consistent with
the certified values and that's the
yellow light
that's a proceed with caution your
pipeline seems to be working well if you
get a red light that's a stop something
went wrong reevaluate your process
important thing to know is that this
doesn't tell you about maybe the disease
variant that you care about but it tells
you about your ability to generally get
reliable information out of your NGS
sequencing pipeline
here's some additional information these
are the samples that are available as
the genome in a bottle certified DNA
samples and here is the vast number of
NGS sequencing platforms that the
samples have been analyzed on the cell
lines for these samples are available
through Coryell and if you'd like to get
any of the certified DNA that is
available through nest one very
interesting use I mentioned standard
data before is how FDA has used this
collaboration as this precision FDA
truth challenge so these genome in a
bottle samples there are now seven total
they were released not all at the same
time and at one point FDA had NIST hold
back the data for the one of the genome
in a bottle samples along with the DNA
we release all of the data that came
from those NGS analyses and so they did
this precision fda truth challenge so
what this is is it allows the it allowed
the user community to take the genome in
a bottle DNA sample do the sequencing do
their use their own tools to do general
assembly of the genome and then that was
submitted to FDA that was then given to
NIST and we assess it to see which
assembler which pipeline gave the
results that were most similar to the
certified values and this was another
unique way to use the kind of outputs
that Mis generates to be able to help
the community in general and then out of
this some new pipelines for DeNoble
assembly were able to be confirmed and
and validated so just to finish off with
NIST what does NIST do and how does this
work with communities NIST works
internationally we work with other
government industry academia we work
nationally internationally so this
really covers basically anybody in a
sector NIST is able to work with and
strives to work with in order to create
harmonization in an area one unique sort
of interaction I'll mention is Mistral
ship with the FDA which we collaborate
with closely missus measurement experts
FDA as regulators who are able to see
pre-competitive needs that man if they
had something that some standard or some
data that would help a field they could
see how it might be able to accelerate a
technology space to be able to develop
therapies that could help people or new
tools that could help people are getting
new kinds of products into the market
and we work regularly with them in order
to be able to do that and support them
as another government agency with our
expertise so now that I've given you an
overview of nest let's dive into the
measurement challenge is seeing that
you're really here for which is the
genome editing and the CRISPR
technologies so how does this really
apply to NIST and the work that we're
doing well let me begin with the scope
of what we're talking about targeted
genome editing and so if we describe
that roughly as the capability to make
targeted DNA sequence changes in life
cells then that's being aggressively
pursued for bioscience applications so
all sorts of applications from basic
research to material sciences to Health
Sciences in agriculture so this is a
sector that really fits well with
something that NIST sees as being able
to have a wide and very deep impact on
the economy and technology so were there
needs that NIST could help with so the
answer came to us very quickly as yes
there were applications that there were
needs in these applications were
particularly high in their need for
having confidence in the kinds of
measurements and the area that came most
strongly forward was those that are
trying to make therapies based on genome
editing so those that are trying to make
gene therapies particularly so the idea
is that there are industry members that
are trying to take cells from patients
be able to use genome editing
for other tools to engineer these cells
and to be able to deliver them back to a
patient as a therapeutic and in addition
to this mode that people are trying to
potentially formulate these genome
editing molecules to be able to say
deliver CRISPR directly into a person
and so the idea of doing that and a new
technology you really need to have very
rigorous measurement science to make
sure that you feel comfortable with
being able to translate this kind of
technology into the clinic if we look at
a very general genome editing overview
then we can bend this into a few very
large bins so let's look at this process
so let's say you start with genome
editing molecules and at the beginning
there are very many kinds of editing
molecules this meeting is focused on
CRISPR but the kinds of tools and things
that NIST generates would be applicable
to Christopher as well as other tools
including zinc fingers talons and the
derivatives of CRISPR Lake bass editors
so once you decide on your target and
what kind of molecule you're going to
use you have to figure out how you're
going to formulate it are you going to
deliver this molecule to cells as DNA as
RNA as protein what's possible what kind
of molecules are you delivering and then
how are you going to get them into the
cell are you going to do some sort of
electroporation are you going to use
some sort of virus as that lentivirus is
it adenovirus is it a nano particle what
is it that you're using then you've got
a hopefully your molecule works and you
get the mechanism of action it's a
strand break single strand double strand
break it's a nick that whatever that
mechanism of action is and then
hopefully if your process is working
then you get an edit generate it as a
result of this DNA a perturbation and
then you need to confirm what you did
and then you've got to determine the fit
for purpose so even after you confirm
what you did is this product fit for the
purpose that you need it for all along
this
this set of places in your process our
places where there can be variability
you can make different choices and
depending on the choices you make that
may impact your output and this is
really where we're helping the community
understand the variability in the
process and understand given the
measurements that they're trying to use
how confident they can be in them so
let's dig a little bit more into this
idea of a gene therapy so you see here
where we start with cells coming out of
a patient then this genome editing
process and what you might get you might
get unedited cells you might get cells
that have your desired edits and you
might have cells that have your
undesired edits both the cells that have
your desired edits they may also have
have undesired edits in addition to your
desired edits so this is a complex kind
of pool that could come out of a genome
editing process and to add to that sort
of complexity of the heterogeneity of
what you might get at the population
level when we dig into that a little bit
more and look at the DNA level how
complex might this be well it can be
very complex so each cell is their own
little bioreactor you can consider it
and what happens in one cell doesn't
determine what's going to happen in
another cell so the events that are
happening where you're at genome editing
molecules are interacting with your DNA
and how many locations they interact
with your DNA
this can be your on target the Edit
location you meant for them to act at
and these off target locations on the
genome you didn't need for them to do
anything at so those vary between cells
because they're completely independent
events and what comes out of this
process can be very complex so because
they're independent events the repair
outcomes within each cell can vary and
because these analyses are done mostly
not at the single cell level it can be
very difficult to do that and expensive
to do you're pooling cells and doing a
sequencing and you may get something
that looks like what we see in the
second step here which is a lot of
variants
at the same location and different kinds
of barriers there generated insertions
deletions maybe single base pair
substitutions and the size of these
insertions and deletions can be larger
or smaller so the ability to detect this
and for your bioinformatics to report
this out appropriately this can be
variable and it's a challenge to
understand NIST recognize this but we
weren't really sure if there was truly a
need in this space so we hosted a
workshop in 2016 and the output of that
was that yes we had very strong
consensus that there was a need for NIST
in the space and that there were ways
for the community to work together in
this space so the things that came out
of this were confidence in existing
assays measurements that you're already
using to assess what happened in your
genome editing experiments that there
should be a little bit more confidence
there informatics and data confidence
norms that man it would be really great
if there was some way of harmonizing
normalizing and understanding of how
variable the data and the informatics
tools to generate that data or analyze
that data are and that there's the space
and opportunity for new assays to meet
unmet measurement capability we followed
up with the field and there here's a
list I'm not going to read it because
you can see it there of questions that
came out that we're consistent across
many different leaders in the field that
were places that NIST might be able to
help the community so what came out of
all of these discussions and here in the
box that has the company logos if a
company's in that box at some point they
participated in the workshops or the
discussions that NIST hosted to
understand what the needs were so what
came out of this was the need for a NIST
consortium to help in this sector and
there were three target areas that were
identified specificity measurements data
and metadata and lexicon which I hadn't
discussed yet and I'll discuss a little
bit more later so I'm going to move on
to the last part of the talk which is
talking about
inest unum editing consortium and I will
go through the general parts of the
consortium and the work that we're
building right now so initiator money
insertion this consortium is active out
of as of June 1st 2018 and the goal of
this consortium is to convene experts
across every sector of the genome
editing field to address the
measurements and standards needs to
increase the confidence of using general
genome editing and the translation of
these tools in research and commercial
products so I've got this diagram again
that we saw earlier and really where
we're acting at is understanding what
assays we need to work with and giving
measurement assurance for assays data
all parts of this process so there are
some consortium goals the goals include
on the assay side qualifying the assays
to evaluate the genome editing outputs
these might be a space for on target and
off target editing they may be a STIs
that you use to assess where in the
genome and editing molecule might have
acted to develop physical reference
materials that allow you to have
something in a bottle something in a
while in your own hands that allows you
to say how well is this assay doing in
my hands to generate reference data so
data and informatics pipelines the data
that might go along with that physical
sample to say how well as my informatics
pipeline doing at getting the similar
result that is generated out of this
consortium and suggested minimum
information guidelines so when you do a
genome editing study when you're doing
your CRISPR experiments when you go to
publish or when you go to post that
information what information should we
always be thinking about putting and
keeping with that to help the next
person that's using that data using that
information know exactly what was done
and lastly generate a common lexicon for
genome editing studies so this is
terminology how are words used when are
they used do they mean the same thing
gene editing the same as genome editing
the same as gene or genome engineer
is a guide RNA the same as a single
guide RNA is it the same as a as the
tracer plus crispr RNA what what are we
talking about and let's have some
normalization which will accelerate and
forward the the commute ability of
studies so our goal at the end of this
consortium is to have shared materials
that can accelerate the field adoption
and translation of genome editing
technologies to products and other
sectors norms that allow for greater
understanding and forwarding the field
of genome editing at an even more rapid
rate improved understanding of our
confidence in detecting on target and
particularly off target genome editing
so you know where it is you know what it
is and then you can begin to say well
what might it be doing or doesn't really
matter
and then harmonize genome editing so
that we can all be speaking the same
language and move forward together so
the things that I just talked about the
goals of the consortium they are divided
into three working groups one is roughly
the working group that we might be able
to call wet lab we call it specificity
measurements the second working group is
the data and metadata working group the
third working group is the lexicon
working group and I'm going to go over
each and every one of these in a little
bit more detail so what I want to share
with you is our current membership of
the consortium so this slide just lists
our current members we're still
accepting members of the consortium and
a members will be accepted on a rolling
basis and members can participate in all
or even just one aspect of the
consortium as they see their expertise
fits so working group one of the
consortium of specificity measurements
so specificially is meant to be a site
qualification which is a term that I
mentioned but didn't really describe and
and also development of reference
materials which I've gone over a little
bit more so as the qualification process
what does this really mean it really
means for you to understand how good
your assay is so if I hug him back to
that list earlier of well how good is
your measurement that's what we're
trying to understand when we do a asset
qualification process at the end of this
I have these steps here that you can
read at the end of this you want to have
an understanding of the precision of an
assay the robustness of an assay the the
dynamic range of an assay and all of
this should be put along with the
metadata so people understand how you
got to those values so for this
consortium we'll first need to identify
one of the core and the most important
assays Furness to evaluate and then
we'll be able to go through this process
with the consortium members to develop
what should be a assessment of these
critical assays that have utility for
especially understanding clinical the
clinical applications of genome editing
CRISPR technologies so understanding the
the assay dynamic range requires the
ability to change variables and assess
how that change impacted your output you
can refine the assays of protocols
establish what the baseline is so what
if you just ran an assay but you didn't
try to do the editing how variable is
just running an assay without trying to
use CRISPR that's very important to know
what your baseline is so when you get a
result you can say is this biologically
relevant or is just the noise of
happening to run this assay and then
after you understand and you've
qualified the assay you can better
understand what you should come out of
this what what control can come out of
this I've discussed reference materials
I'm going to put this up here one of the
important things about reference
materials is to specify what the
material needs to do for you it's not
going to do everything it's not meant to
do everything but what is it actually
going to do for you
design it to do that and then test its
ability to do that and for this
consortium we're looking at DNA based
reference materials so won't control for
the editing process itself it won't
control for DNA extraction but it would
control for after you have an edited
sample and you want to assess it this is
where you could carry this forward and
use it to assess the rest of your
process and the rest of your assays you
use so one of the ways the stream in a
bottle reference material that I
mentioned earlier it's very useful and
helpful for understanding general genome
editing but something that looks like
I'm sorry it's helpful to understand
general NGS sequencing but for something
that looks like genome editing you're
going to need something that has the
complexity that looks like 18 ohm edited
sample so here's again a another way of
looking at the simplified genome editing
process and I just mentioned the asset
qualification on the reference materials
and at the point where you might screen
for just Romek disruption now you're not
necessarily saying what happened but
where something happened assay
qualification can be helpful because
these assays many of them are newer and
haven't been qualified the way that say
NGS has been qualified and where you're
using some of these sequencing types of
assays for the genome editing
application a reference material that
gives you something that looks like a
genome editing is the kind of fit that
we're we're working towards so just
briefly I'm gonna round out here with
what is this kind of thing that NIST
might generate so this was an original
idea where we would have a DNA sample
we might spike in variants that look
like genome editing know might you see
that and maybe say okay well we've got
all of these different genome editing
variants which what mixture should we
use should it be 10% of
this a and then 2% of the sea and then
1% of this two base pair deletion what
does that look like so this is a process
that we were thinking about implementing
and we got some feedback we thought
about it a little bit more and this
isn't really the actual fit for for a
purpose that we're gonna go forward with
the idea of a spike in it doesn't really
suit all the many ways that a genome
editing sample might be used and the
kinds of assays people might want to use
it for so engineering invariance to make
it control seems like a much better
process that will allow you to have some
more control and have variance in
context that might be more valuable than
short I'll ago that spiked into a large
batch of DNA so we refined the thought
process out of after some additional
thought and input from experts as to
what really would be valuable for them
is engineering in variance into cells
and growing up single-cell clonal
populations extracting DNA measuring the
DNA that come from the independent
single-cell clonal populations and then
determining what mixture would be
helpful as a mimic of on target and off
target DNA editing so the outputs from
this would be a series of DNA process
control materials and mixed samples as
well as unmixed samples will be provided
we would you see these assays with
choosing these samples with qPCR and NGS
sequencing and those assays and the data
from those assays would be an output of
this as well as the data and all of the
metadata associated with this as an
output and a tool to be used by the
community so briefly I'm just going to
mention working group two and working
group three working group two is data
and metadata so data and metadata simply
there is a
need to both capture information have
ways of sharing the information and
comparing the information and so this
comes in really two flavors for for what
this working group is going to do which
is community norms for minimum
information reporting which I've
mentioned earlier what are these terms
how would they be housed how would we
share this data add metadata and
community norms for data formats and
tools for benchmarking analysis what is
a minimum norm for a data file format so
that different kinds of informatics
tools can use the same file to be able
to process and there are different
informatics tools is there some set of
norms to understand how to compare
outputs from different bioinformatics
tools
lastly the lexicon working group so the
lexicon working group is meant to come
to some minimum norms on terminology and
so if we have that it should enable
clear communication of scientific
results facilitate communication within
the expert community and with regulators
like FDA and the USDA and have the
potential for international acceptance
international terminology norms so right
now we have this pilot list of terms
that we are trying to narrow down a
first list of terms to begin to define
minimum definitions and so we're looking
for a high priority list of maybe about
20 terms that are used differentially or
used in in ambiguous ways or ways that
are inconsistent either within any
particular subfield or across different
fields maybe between human applications
and non-human applications and and begin
to generate a pilot definition that we
can share widely with the community
here's a link on this slide that you can
go to that website and give information
about this minimum list that we're
gathering so lastly there was and we do
share and interact widely through
workshops
and there was recently a NIST FDA
workshop to basically share FDA's
perspective on what they might see as
needs if you're wanting to use CRISPR
genome editing for regulated purpose
isn't about therapies and through this
we were able to clarify regulatory
perspectives and what I just shared with
you all I shared at this workshop and
got some of the the refinement and
additional input and we were able to
identify and get some more input for a
path forward so workshops are another
way that we interact with the community
and I welcome you to participate in
future NIST workshops so lastly the path
for success so this trying to help the
genome editing field to impact and
create greater outputs for the science
that you're doing in the CRISPR field
this is the path for success we want to
continue signing up consortium
participants including international and
within the u.s. of different expertise
is to figure out their most effective
contributions identify the experts that
can contribute to the reference material
development analysis as well as the data
and metadata and to be able to integrate
all of these activities across what's
being developed in the experimental wet
lab side with the data and informatics
and the terminology experts so thank you
so much for participating in this talk
and I look forward to helping you as
NIST and thank you dr. mirage for that
informative presentation we will now
start the Q&A portion of our webinar and
we'll address some of the most commonly
asked questions by our viewers if you
have any questions you'd like to ask
please do so now just click on that ask
a question drop down box located on the
far left of your presentation window
type your questions into that box that
appear on the screen and click the send
button our speaker will follow up with
your questions via email so let's take a
look at some of the questions from our
viewers
so garage does everyone need to use
standards or is this just for the
industry so in terms of standards I
think
it depends on what you're doing what
kind of confidence tool you need but as
scientist we should be introducing some
sorts of standards into our work and in
this aspect the kinds of things that you
need to do this idea of fit for purpose
what are you doing and what is your fit
for purpose and if you want to be able
to trust your data you need to implement
some sort of standard or norm whether
it's within your own hands but shared
norms are definitely an important thing
and and I would hope that the audience
would be interested engaging in defining
what it is that you really need because
these things should be developed by
consensus in order to fit a need that
you have thank you and will any of these
standards be required for publication so
we don't require anything as NIST but we
have had interactions with some journals
that are very interested in the idea of
minimum information norms they are a
regular part of other aspects of other
fields this has been involved with qPCR
and digital PCR minimum information
norms and those have been adopted as
expected norms that people would follow
when they publish on those sorts of data
so it may be something that becomes part
of the publication infrastructure
although NIST wouldn't be the one that
implements anything like that
and dr. mirage what about CRISPR for
other applications besides medicine so
that's a very important and very
valuable field the field that we've been
focusing on for this initial consortium
work has been the gene therapy field
it's been the one that had really come
forward the most and said that they had
a really pressing need and that was
consistent with what we were hearing
from FDA
but a lot of the tools that we're
developing are really fundamental
capabilities so your ability to
understand if you have a
edited sample and how good is your NGS
and your hands to detect things that
look like a genome edited sample there
may be some differences between
applications but that's a core
competency so we're trying to get down
to core competencies data metadata even
though our use case is is gene therapy
for the most part that's a core
capability that goes beyond just medical
applications of these tools and
certainly terminology our goal is to
make sure that the minimum terminology
is applicable to all fields and not just
for a medical use of that term dr. Marrs
thank you for being our keynote
presenter today do you have any closing
remarks you'd like to provide our
viewers I appreciate you having me today
I encourage all of you NIST is here to
collaborate with and to help the
community at large I encourage you to
get in touch with me I'm leading the
genome editing program as well as the
consortium if you have any questions but
but NIST is here to do things to
accelerate this field and I just look
forward to working with this community
more in the future thank you as well and
thank you again for your important
research I'd also like to thank lab
roots for making today's educational
webcast possible before we go I want to
remind everyone that today's webcast
will be available for on-demand viewing
through January 2019 you'll receive an
email from laborat letting you know that
the webcast will be available for replay
please share that announcement with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
event that's all for now and thank you
for joining us we hope to see you again
soon bye bye